Kevin Mike describes without talking
about the movies that you didn't like of
his this was a pretty quick yes yeah and
you know you know Michaels Michaels a
world-class writer and and he did send
me five scripts between I have such a
man who's counting so it was and because
they were world-class scripts they were
just near misses for me
they were just near misses and and you
want something to kind of stand out for
you in a way that it's almost like
seeing a UFO and I think most of us are
glad if we have never seen a UFO because
I would ruin the rest of our life
because for the rest of our life we have
to tell our friends so this UFO and
everybody goes oh poor Kevin poor do you
know what happened to Bob he saw UFO I
mean and so I have you know I've seen
some things like this in my life I have
I've seen Dances with Wolves I saw Field
of Dreams I saw American movie called
Bull Durham and I saw this little movie
called black or white and it spoke out
loud to me because I because like the
nation I've struggled with this subject
you know we all struggle with how
delicate this thing is and we don't seem
to be able to have this conversation and
the genius I think of Mike's writing was
he put it in the mouth of a drunk of a
grandfather who was fighting for the
last connection to the two women he
loved the most his wife and his daughter
and it gets dirty at in the end and Mike
wrote such an even-handed screenplay
that I was stunned and when I came and
when I was when I was done reading it I
felt like I had a better handle about
how to have this discussion I played
baseball my whole life and when James
Earl Jones actually get that great
speech and filled of Dreams
I felt different about baseball and when
I heard Mike speech about it's not my
first thought that counts it's my second
and my third and my fourth it ends up
defining whether or not I'm a racist and
it helped me and sometimes movies can do
that you know movies can live forever
because they move us because
a great romance because of a kiss
because of action because of laughter
comedy and once in a while a movie can
get under your skin and sometimes a
movie can help you wrestle with a
subject that you haven't been able to
get a handle on and Mike did that and
that's no simple thing and so when I saw
it I knew that I I knew that we would
make it and I thought the town would
come rushing to make this movie and it
didn't happen but I had made Mike a
promise that we would and so I walked
down the hall one morning and I'd like
my wife's are stand up for a second
Christine would you stand up please and
I walk I walk down the hall and she was
in our den and I said Chris I promised
Mike we'd make this movie and I think we
were gonna have to pay for it and she
said what and I said I think we're gonna
have to pay for it and I said it it
reminds me of everything it is I love
about movies and I said and I happen to
think it's highly entertaining and she
just simply said to me she didn't think
about all our security what in the world
she just said if you really want to do
this and I think that that's what you
should do so I told her later I was
going to go build a cornfield right
after that but if I know Kristin never
seeks a limelight but I thought it was
important that she stood up because as
my partner she said I'll back you in
making this movie so it was the fifth
screenplay I believed in it and we made
it Mike I want to hear a little bit
about what happened in your life that
inspired you to write this movie well
you know it was inspired by real events
in my life you know my wife who's here
also her sister died when she was 32 of
AIDS and she had a little seven-year-old
boy who was a biracial boy and who
didn't have a relationship with his
father but he
a great relationship with his
grandmother in his aunt's and his
cousins and Diane really took took him
in and and and who was involved with
raising him and so I being her husband I
I helped you know but but really she did
the work and and he was part of our
family and still is to this day and and
he's an amazing man now he's 34 years
old but the the inspiration was that he
had a family down in South Central and
we lived in Santa Monica and they were
two completely different worlds and he
was everybody in both worlds was saw him
as either black or white and he never
saw himself as anything other than just
a little kid you know and he didn't see
any fascination with the fact you know
and I thought one day that'd be a good
way to tell the story about what's going
on and how hard it is to talk about
what's going on away from the police and
the news and the politicians and in the
guns you know and the helicopters you
know right down on the earth a story
about a family but really a story about
about race you know and Octavia I'll ask
you this question this feels like a
movie that had it been told ten years
ago would be totally different there's
something about this moment in time that
changes the conversations that we're
having about this film conversations
were having about a lot of things for me
I don't know that the conversation would
be different because I when I read it I
just loved the symmetry in both worlds
we had two families both dealing with
some sort of addiction both dealing with
some sort of trauma but at the center of
it was everybody loved this child and so
for me it would the family part would
always be first and that's just kind of
the way that I you know see things but I
do get that raises a
it is a conversation that is danced
around and I love the fact that Mike and
Kevin you know we're brave enough to say
you know what this is a conversation
that needs to be had and what a
wonderful introduction or an entree to
to begin it but for me I just love that
at the end of the day it was about the
love of this child and how broad her
world could be with both families Mike
is there some prep Kevin said something
that I really always said the idea was
never to make a movie that was the
conversation it was a idea was to make a
movie that started conversation the idea
was you'd say you know you want to make
a movie that people go have a cup of
coffee afterwards cuz a lot of times
nowadays I feel like you go to movies
and you just go home and you get on your
phone or your iPad and you don't really
discuss the movies anymore you got on
your phone during the movie you've been
in the theaters either when you were
talking about the movie though I'm gonna
pick up on something like Teddy was
talking about did you talk about it as a
movie about a family and let more so or
equally so about that as opposed to a
movie about race well both but the world
changed I want to say you know you know
one thing about Kevin you know early on
you know there was a thing where right
while we were shooting the movie I'm
Paula Deen her whole kind of world fell
apart like that while we were shooting
it and the George Zimmerman thing was
going on and and there was a lot of talk
about you know should Kevin really use
the n-word that way in the movie and
then you know should we shoot an
alternative and he was like there's no
way there's no I'm not even shooting an
alternative because I don't want to ever
use it you know and and the fact is you
know because it really wasn't about that
it was you know and and you know so I
think that you know it's just one of
those things where you just go okay just
stay with the original vision even
though the work because everything
that's happened that everyone throws up
right now about guarding it's weird that
you made this movie in the time
none of that happened before we made
this movie Ferguson and George Zimmerman
and all that well I think it's proof
that that for the people who believe
we're in a post-racial world were not
Kevin I would talk about the the scene
the courtroom this monologue however you
want to describe it when you're reading
the script for the first time and you're
making it kind of all sorts of decisions
about the movie do you Kalama into
certain scenes do you see that scene is
that something you talk about in your
earliest conversations with Mike about
how that scene is gonna work in the film
well I you know I've had a quite a life
in the movies and I've loved every
minute of it it doesn't mean it hasn't
been a life bruised I've taken some big
bites out of life and life's taking some
big bites out of me but I keep coming
back to the movies and you know I have a
romance with them and I remember seeing
Spencer Tracy and inherit the wind and
thought he wasn't afraid of the language
and you know I play action movies
sometimes and you know anybody that does
actually they want less words less words
but I I my roots go back to these guys
and I thought one day I'm gonna get a
speech like that and I'm not gonna cut
out a word and I got it in JFK I got a
little speech in Bull Durham about the
small of a woman's back you know and
I've had some speeches in my life and
when I read this thing that micro it's
no small thing you could take a hundred
of her best writers in Hollywood to
tackle this subject and I don't know
that anybody would come up with such an
American point of view that Mike has
done so it's no small feat and I just
when I realized how good it was I also
realized that I was the person that
could screw it up and because I was the
one that was gonna have to deliver it
and it's now your speech because it
helped me and when he said you know he's
never once apologized to my wife I
didn't know I was gonna bubble up
emotionally there but that was at its
core sometimes all we need in life isn't
apology something deep down that was
like at its core and it was a beautiful
American speech it's a very American
screenplay and I was I wasn't going to
I'm kind of like a I'm pretty fierce
about things and one of them is about
intent and I don't like audiences
telling us what to do with our movies I
wanted you to see this in a dark and
it's purity with with all the words I
wasn't afraid of any of the words in
this movie I was afraid to not say them
and so I got to thank Mike for that
speech because no matter what I have it
forever and and if in somehow informs
you and your life that's why actually
deep down in my heart I actually thought
it could